Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed Noble
And fully self-enlightened.
Noreen keeps up her group of Skype.
About four or five of them.
Who discuss the Dharma.
And they take a book or they take something.
And this was something that came up for them.
She sent it to me because there was a question about something.
Which we will come to later.
So Meichi Kyo is a Taifo Shunan.
Who is recognized as a fully liberated being.
And this is one of her statements, and we'll use it to find out how we can get there, even this week.
Body, mind and essence are all distinct and separate realities.
Absolutely everything is known.
Earth, water, fire and wind.
Body, feeling, memory, thought and consciousness.
Sounds, sights, smells, tastes, touches and emotions.
Anger, greed and delusion all are known.
I know them all as they exist in their own natural states.
But no matter how much I am exposed to them, I am unable to detect even an instant when they have any power over my heart.
They arise and cease.
They are forever changing.
But the presence that knows them never changes for an instant.
It is forever unborn and undying.
This is the end of suffering.
That's pretty clear.
So, how do we get to this point, I wonder?
The end of suffering.
We'll come back to this in a moment, because if we want to teach people the Dharma,
then we've got to be pretty clear ourselves about the basic tinnitus, the basic position of the Buddha took.
And to actually be able to feel that you have the internal logic of his teaching, the internal rationality of his teaching, to make that bold statement, you know, there is an end of suffering.
I don't think there's a single Western psychologist or school that says there's an end to suffering.
They've always got maybe...
Maybe if they were Christians, they would have thought so.
But in the sense of there being an end of suffering right here in this very life, I think that's quite a bold statement to make.
So, just for us to revise, really, just to go through our minds, the four basic truths that the Buddha taught.
This truth of dukkha, you see.
Remember, dukkha means something
Hard to bear, that's its sort of translation.
Hard to bear.
It's not only referring to the pains and aches of the body and the emotional upsets, the pressures and the stress of life.
It always boils down to these three characteristics.
That our deep suffering, the deeper level of existential suffering, comes about because we're not actually seeing things as they really are.
That's his normal statement.
Now that statement, which is a translation of the Pali, isn't actually absolutely correct.
The translation is to see and understand how things have come to be.
So this is the Buddha.
He's interested in process.
So when we, today for instance, when we're just observing the process of eating, see?
It's the whole process that we are trying to engage with, trying to understand.
How is it that we create this world within this psychophysical organism, this body and mind, this fathom-length body, as the Buddha puts it.
Within this fathom-length body is the world, the creation of the world, etc., etc.
And it's really beginning to understand that we are limited by the body.
as to what we can experience anyway.
And then whatever information the body gives us is always taken inward and fixed into our concepts about things.
And these concepts about things are built up from past perceptions.
So, very simply, today we had chili beans, you see.
Well, we've probably made our own chili beans and had chili beans elsewhere.
So as soon as we tasted these chili beans,
we knew whether they were the real chili beans or not because either they're not the proper chili beans or they are the proper chili beans or they're almost the proper chili beans so it's this judging mind and that's something else remember judging there's a distinction between judging and judgmental but putting that aside this whole process of creating the world within ourselves having this
memory of past events reliving really the world through our particular memory patterns and that's the sankaras that's our habits see so when the buddha talks about this dukkha he's sort of digging deep at the level of our perception how we perceive things and one of them is that we perceive continuity and we actually really do believe that you know
The person, me, who got up this morning, well, I'm pretty well the same person now.
I don't see, I don't experience myself arising and passing away.
I experience myself as absolutely constant within a mass of change.
It's me always that's doing stuff.
And it's getting down to that anicca, getting down to this real deep level of impermanence is to see that the actual self is arising and passing away, the sense of me
arises with every experience I'm having, momentary experience I'm having.
So, this again digs even deeper to the point of identity.
Now, here in this statement, you see, she says, I am unable to detect, even for an instant, when they have any power over my heart.
See, to have power is to have control, it's the self.
Whenever you say, you know, this is me,
and then you define it.
If you say, I am, and you put something at the end of that sentence, I am angry, I am happy, I am an engineer, I am a nurse, whatever you say after that, you're locked into that definition, even if only for that moment, for that time.
And that's how we define ourselves.
When that definition disappears, then of course at times it can send us into a process of not knowing who we are.
So you get this crisis, an identity crisis.
I remember that I used to have a Tai Chi teacher.
He was a lovely man.
And I stopped going.
And I met him years on.
Well, not that far on, maybe two or three years on.
And he was half the man I remember him.
And I said, what's happened?
I thought he'd had an illness.
He said, no, he just lost his job.
So with his job, lost his debt.
It wasn't only the pain of loss of the income, you know, which we were finding out.
But the whole self-definition of who he was and what his position was in the world, it was just taken away from him.
And he had the usual depression and all that sort of stuff that comes with that loss of identity.
And of course, the final loss of identity is when they lay us out in the morgue.
I mean, that's when we know we've lost our identity.
So the way the Buddha sort of digs really deep, and it's a place, of course, that
most therapies don't want to go it's a bit frightening to get down to that level but that's where we want to get to we want to get down to this business of who am I before I describe myself before there's something coming after the am I am whatever and it's because remember because of this deep delusion as to who I am meaning this body, this heart, this mind this person see this person
Which exists, by the way.
The person exists in the sense that it's momentary.
It's a momentary total conception of me.
There are experiences in meditation where you can step out of the self.
It's a bit strange, but you can step out of it and you see, oh, there's the self.
And that self, but it's not permanent.
That's the problem.
Now, because of this identity thing,
of this identity of being this person, then remember that I have this relationship with the world now.
And when we ask ourselves, how do I want to be?
How do I want to be?
What do I want to be?
I think we've come to this word, happy.
I just want to be happy, for heaven's sake.
Everybody will define their happiness in their own way, but that I want to be happy is just, that's all I want to be.
you want to be happy and because of this delusion though remember we seek the happiness in in just these wrong places and and that's where we form attachments and attachments are simply our psychological dependency on something and then we find we don't have control over it and so and so the whole gamut of human misery starts you know the frustration grief etc and of course once you once you've gained something you've got to protect it one way or the other you know whether it's against
some nasty person or a government, you've got to protect what you have.
And so there's that aversion and the fear of loss.
So you can see from this deep delusion that arises a more tangible dukkha.
I mean, if you were to say to somebody, are you suffering?
They'd probably point to these sorts of things, you know, like I'm depressed, my job's not going well, my relationship's collapsing, all that sort of stuff.
so they're pointing to something actually concrete and something they can actually feel and explain but at a deeper level we have this inexplicable sense of identity you see and you can see from her statement that something's missing there isn't it because no matter what's happening to her at any level it doesn't have any power over her heart in other words
She cannot be grasped by it.
She cannot be lost in it.
Deluded by it.
So that's.
That's where the Buddha puts his.
You know.
Stakes out his cause.
There is Dukkha.
And there's no way.
There can't be Dukkha.
That's the point.
There's no way.
For us.
With the idea of a self.
There can be anything but Dukkha in the end.
And even when we are.
totally happy when things are going perfectly right and the world is full of gold and shining there is always that awful feeling underneath that things are passing that you don't have control over it so nothing can give us absolute total satisfaction again it's usually expressed in the negative the presence that knows them never changes for an instant
See, this is the end of suffering.
So, in terms of how we would normally define our happiness, normally define a state of adukha, not suffering, we would normally define it in a very positive way, such as, you know, feeling happy, going on holiday, having a good job, all that sort of stuff.
We would actually define it as some sort of existing experience.
But this can't be that, can it?
Because she's opted out of all experiences.
This is a presence that knows.
Never changes for an instant.
It's forever unborn and undying.
In other words.
It's not part of the process.
Of the phenomenal world.
That we're experiencing.
Which is arising and passing away.
Complete distinct from it.
This is the end of suffering.
So.
Our question is then.
What is.
The next position that the Buddha takes is.
What's the cause of it?
Now.
He doesn't, having stated these three delusions of Anitta, Dukkha and Atta, he doesn't drive at the cause, this is an important point, he doesn't drive at the cause of being, the problem is identity.
That's not where he's positioning us because that would be impossible to work with directly.
He's pointing to how this delusion and this wrong identity manifests
And it manifests in our desires.
So then he gives us this dependent origination.
Which is in the second noble truth.
He tries to point out to us where the weak link is in this whole process of creating suffering for ourselves.
And you'll notice that at the base you've got this sense of ignorance.
Now remember that ignorance is not culpable.
It's not as though we should have known better.
It's a state of not knowing.
And just like we don't know some things.
we then presume to know or we think we know or we make a guess or we take a leap and it's usually into some sort of pit see so it's accepting that at the base of our the fundamental part of us is a state of not knowing and this remember translates into the heart as a sense of innocence so from a moral heart point of view you know compassion joy and peace
We start from the point of innocence, which means not doing harm.
It's the Latin, no harm.
So there's no harm and not knowing are combined to form what she's referring to here as body-mind, mind especially.
I don't know what words she's referring to in the Pali.
The Buddha uses words contextually
Sometimes they seem to contradict each other if you're actually going just for a word.
So take the word chitta.
Chitta could be translated in our language as the combination of mind and heart.
The old word soul as opposed to spirit.
Psyche.
We split those in our enlightenment period, you know, in the
Great 18th century enlightenment.
So that we think of ourselves as rational beings and or feeling beings, you know.
So you get people say, I think, and then others say, I feel, see.
So this split is something that we have, which has, of course, had its brighter side.
It's brought about science and technology and all that.
But in the Buddha's understanding, that would all be just one faculty.
And that's known as citta, see.
And yet in his victory verse, the one that we chant in the morning, he says he's achieved the asankatam chittam.
So he's achieved something which is not conditioned.
That obviously can't be the body, the mind-heart matrix.
So we have to be careful about, I don't know what words she's referring to here.
So we have this dependent origination, you see, and
need to be clear about that we need to be clear as to why the buddha taught it so he's teaching us how we create the world and it's it's it's the creation in time because these these uh links uh don't always come at the same time the first the first few are always there at any given time so there's always that not knowing beneath everything we do a sense of
which express themselves as a lack of wisdom.
And because of that, we've created these delusions, these sankara.
And they're running underneath every moment as a potential, like a program in a computer.
And then you have a moment of action, a moment that drops into this flow, you might say.
Of course, they're momentary, arising and passing away and all that.
But even so, you've got this drop into the moment,
And that's when you get the body, mind and consciousness.
And he separates them, you see.
The body and mind are one matrix, the body and the mind working off each other.
So that's what we do when we're eating.
We're seeing that there's the body taste, the heart responds with a bit of joy and so on.
So that matrix is always happening and there's the consciousness of it.
So consciousness here, you have to be careful, it's a discriminative consciousness.
There is included in there, shall we say, a certain knowing, a certain habitual way of discriminating things.
Just even at a very simple perceptual level.
You know that when Cook arrived in Australia,
the Aborigines didn't see the ships because they didn't have a context in which to see them.
It's the same with me.
When I was in Sri Lanka, I heard this barking.
For some reason, I hadn't associated that sort of noise, barking, with monkeys.
And when they told me it was monkeys and they were up there, for the life of me, I couldn't see them.
And they were just amazed that I couldn't see these monkeys.
And then suddenly I saw them, you know, because I had a picture of a monkey in my eye.
They go, surrounded by blooming monkeys.
Ah, I didn't see this.
is astonishing really so that whole process has to be should we say put onto a screen and that's your vijnana but it also includes all the knowledge and the intelligence all the knowledge and the understanding that we have is on that screen see now once that's happened remember so you've got the body you've got the splitting up of that into the five into the six
ayatana now ayatana are spheres and what all the buddha is saying is that each sphere is distinct and discrete so you can't hear through your eyes and you can't you can't see through your ears it's just one of those things i know there's this thing about synesthesia but i think that's just in the mind that's the mind itself working on it inside inside that's the sixth sense right
The fact is that you're never going to hear through your eyes whether you like it or not.
So it's sort of recognizing that we experience the world through very different avenues, which we have to collect onto this screen.
So even here, you can hear me, you can see me, you can feel the atmosphere of this room.
All of that is happening in little blitz and blobs, but somehow it's held on this screen.
And that's what the Vijnana is referring to.
Now when that's held there, we have our moment-to-moment contacts.
So there has to be those three things there.
An object, the sense base, and that consciousness, that holding on a screen for us.
Now it's the next point which turns this world into likeable or unlikable.
And that's the Vedana.
And once we've experienced something like that, remember, there's always a reaction to it, of always wanting to make the world pleasant for myself and get rid of anything that's unpleasant.
And it's at that point that we see the escape.
The escape is between experiencing things as pleasant and unpleasant and seeing how we're reacting to it, which is then creating a relationship to it
Now, if we see that, we also become aware that actually even at this point there's no suffering.
Have you grasped that in your meditation?
Have you seen that when you're aware of, say, pain in the knee, and you're aware of aversion to the pain, not wanting it, if those two become clear objects in your mind, you're not actually suffering.
Even at that point, you're not actually suffering.
It's only at the next point when
as it were, you dive into, you lose yourself in that reaction, and you become, I don't want.
So the point of real suffering is always at the point of identity.
Now, the question is, who's suffering?
It's the Buddha who's suffering.
The Buddha's suffering, and that's why he wants to get out of suffering.
See, there's no suffering as such in the body and mind.
All there is, is what is pleasant and unpleasant.
The point of suffering is when this very thing, you see, this very thing, I am unable to detect, even instant, when they have power over my heart.
Right?
This knowing.
As soon as this heart or this knowing falls into that wrong identity, it's that which is suffering.
It's the Buddha's suffering, and the Buddha wants to get out of suffering.
See?
So grasping that, what's happening at the point of identity is that this Buddha within us is actually losing itself through the delusion, that initial delusion of believing that true happiness is to be found in the sensual world.
Sensual here means the whole phenomenal world, the world that's being created by the mind out of quite minimal data, I believe.
So then, of course, having said that this is the cause, he then tells us how to do it, just missing that third step about Nibbana, the end of suffering.
He then tells us how we're actually going to achieve this.
And you'll notice that it's completely systemic.
The fact that just because we understand something or see something doesn't necessarily mean that it's going to become systemic.
So just seeing, for instance, how
desire arises when we're eating and we know that there's an overlay of greed there's an overlay of attachment to the food an overlay of wanting to seek happiness there just the seeing of that clearly clearly clearly even though we see it absolutely clear it's clearly not enough because we keep being greedy so so there's something else that has a problem here and
And then when we look down into the lie, we find attitude.
Now, attitude refers to these conditionings within us, what our attitude is.
And when we look at one of them, this selfishness, which manifests as anything we do for our own good, for our own benefit, driven by the idea that this is happiness.
That's always the internal delusion there.
When we see that, in fact, it has to be hit at an attitudinal level.
Now, how do you change at an attitudinal level?
It's by seeing these intentions.
By seeing these intentions, and that's why this is such a strong teaching within the Mahasi's tradition, the Mahasi Sado's tradition.
To see an intention is to see the manifestation, the initial manifestation of a delusion.
an initial manifestation of a habit that we've created which is unwholesome for us.
So as soon as I see this desire for scones, for instance, arise tomorrow, as soon as that desire hits me, I say, oh, that's the old greed.
I'm hoping it's as good as last.
So it's actually catching that moment.
Now, if we have this mindfulness, this awareness, this alertness to actually be with that,
then we'll allow it to exhaust itself.
And every time we do that, we're drawing energy from that old habit.
So that this compact energy that we've got now directed just towards this object that we call a scone is now being drawn out.
So tomorrow, when the scone is there, you'll be able to say, I'm going to renounce the scone and sit with the pain.
Of renunciation.
Knowing that this pain is a healing pain.
Because it's drawing the poison out of the system.
When all that's gone.
And you feel perfectly equanimous.
Then of course you can have your scone.
But not without.
Clearly seeing.
Any arising of greed for the scone.
After that.
So.
On the opposite of course.
Is that when the intention is seen as wholesome.
Then we empower it.
And in this sense, the heart's growing.
So when we look at right attitude, it's normally put in those three ways, isn't it?
Selfishness to generosity, hatred to love, cruelty to compassion.
Cruelty to compassion.
Now you'll notice that there's no in-between state.
You're either greedy or you're not greedy.
There's not an in-between state there.
So I've tended these days to use the word sublimate rather than transform because it immediately changes.
So as soon as you let out this greedy feeling and you just let it burn itself out, that energy is not lost.
It's there as potential and it'll be used for the right intention.
And in this way, the growth toward light, see from darkness to light as the Buddha says, becomes a natural process through this process of enunciation.
and that's what we mean by renunciation remember it's not we're not trying to beat ourselves up we're just trying to really feel those initial intentions and to stay steady amongst them and wait for it to just to die away and then of course the intention there of course it doesn't finish there does it because then it has to translate into the way we speak to what we do and into our livelihood so in other words
It has to manifest.
Now, remember that an intention, unless it's empowered, hasn't done anything.
It's not what we call a kamma, an act.
So just my feeling greedy is, shall we say, an energy coming out of a past habit, but it's not been potentialized.
Nothing's happened.
Have you heard about the rule about stealing from monks?
Have I explained that to you?
All the different levels of stealing that a monk can get up to when he's really bad.
Have you heard it?
I think you have.
What it points out is very clearly the distinction between these processes.
For instance, if I pass
uh if i pass i know this this um this gong and i i sort of like it i can feel the draw to it of wanting it and if i just let that go you see then it'll disappear but if i don't and i and my mind sort of works on it then i might get a really greed for it and at some point passing it again my hand might stretch out to it you see now and then i pull it back think what are you doing you fool and
but I've already committed what's known as a dukkata this is a small offence against the Vinaya and if I'm lazy minded and I don't watch my thoughts and next time I really sort of go for it and I think yeah I do want it and I put my finger on it and that's agaro that's a very heavy offence however if I then
Under a point of weakness.
Because I'm so entranced by this gong.
I reach out.
And I move it.
A nano centimeter.
And then pull my hand back.
You see.
And go.
That's it.
I've done it.
That's the theft.
It's completed.
See.
I can't.
I lose my rose.
There's no way you can get beyond that.
Even if.
And I don't even get the gong.
I left it there.
It's absolutely useless.
But the act was done.
You see.
So you can see.
You can see through these.
This lovely way that the Vinaya splits up the way that we create a bad act by not seeing that initial intention.
So in the same way, of course, we sometimes have initial good intentions, but we don't act upon them.
But it's actually catching a good intention and then making that effort.
So that translates.
So in other words, an attitude is potential.
And it manifests its potential in an intention.
And the intention still remains potential until it's intentioned.
An intention has to be intentioned.
It's this peculiar language we've got.
And then you commit an act.
And that act can be of an internal thought.
So you're creating a thought which is malevolent.
It can be an act of speech.
It can be an act of something that we've done.
And it's our livelihood.
And when you think of livelihood, you think, well, why would he put that in?
Because it comes under action, really.
That's what we do.
But he's pointing out that what we do for the best part of our lives, in a sense, our work in society, it's where we put a tremendous amount of our energy, is conditioning us.
So it
If you work in a pub, that's one place.
And if you work in a nursery, that's another place, as an effect.
It's not as though these places are essentially, pubs are essentially evil, but it'd be difficult not to have an occasional drink.
So if you look back on your life and the work you've done, and just consider the effect it had on you as a personality, as a...
as a character-forming thing.
And then, of course, subsisting all that is this mindfulness, right concentration, right mindfulness, and right effort.
And that's, of course, always to do with a certain level of awareness, a certain being here.
And that's, of course, very difficult for us because we're constantly forgetting to do that.
And so this idea of stopping as often as we can during the day
And just reestablishing that sense of presence.
You see.
Look what she says you see.
But the presence that knows.
The presence that knows.
We have to reestablish that every moment.
Even though the presence that knows.
May still be a little off.
May still have a chink in the eye.
It's still a presence that knows.
And it's constantly going back.
To that presence that knows.
That is the reminder.
And then.
Once we're in that presence that knows, to make sure that the intention that we're going to actually act out and go into and absorb into, this is the point, absorb into, is going to help us to maintain that presence.
Now, remember that when we're in action, well, no, let's go back to the sitting meditation.
In the sitting meditation, we're always trying to get this presence that knows, to be the presence that knows, to find that place within us of the observer, that observation post, where we can see things that are happening within this body, heart, and mind.
Now, when we're in that position, to really recognize it as something transcendent,
It's no longer caught up in what's happening.
So there may be pain in the knee and there may be a reaction to it of aversion but there's no doing.
There's just that happening.
Within what?
Within that presence.
Within that awareness.
When you hear a bird or a song of a bird there is the sound of the eardrum and you can clearly see it.
It's there in the ear and then you can feel that your heart might lift unless it's
or one of these raucous crows, but if it's a nice little bird, then your heart lifts and you can see that, you see, but you're not, you don't get lost in it, you're observing it, you see.
Now, even though we want to get to that position and stabilize it in our meditation, remember that's only a first position in terms of what we want to do.
The second position is to become so
curious about what's happening within this body our mind that we center in on something and as we do that we absorb into it now because we've absorbed into that whatever's happening within us some emotional state some feeling we've gone into it with the right intention to understand the dharma when we come out of that and we're back to being the observer and whatnot we've actually developed that sense of curiosity
And with it we've developed an understanding because we've gone into the subject in a more intimate way.
Now in the opposite side, when we absorb into something with a bad intention, you come out the other side with that being developed.
So that's why this process of right awareness is paramount in our practice.
To be aware, to keep bringing ourselves back into the present moment.
is the practice, that's all it is.
You can file it down, you can put all the Buddha's teachings in terms of the practice into that one word, sati, samasati.
So, how can we now understand what she's saying here?
So the body, mind and essence are all distinct and separate realities.
Now, I'm presuming that what she means by the essence is this very sense of presence.
Because all there is is body and mind and essence.
Remember this is translating the Thai.
It's all second hand, second hand.
Absolutely everything is known.
So within that field of awareness nothing is blocked out.
Nothing is separated out or put to one side or given special attention or whatever.
It's just
It's just the stuff that arises through this psychophysical organism.
So earth, water, fire and wind.
So these are the four elements.
Remember those four elements don't exist out there.
I mean I know it's put as earth, water, fire and wind.
What they're telling us is how the mind contacts matter.
The mind contacts matter by way of this sensibility to heat,
to elasticity to pressure and to movement and then there's the body feeling the body the feeling memory thought and consciousness so you remember that you can actually when you're observing something you're observing something on that screen of consciousness so it's there there's nothing behind it there's nothing behind it you can't get behind it you can't get through it
That's it.
That's the world we're living in.
Whatever we're conscious of.
Now here's a funny statement.
This is why Noreen emailed me.
Anger, greed and delusion are all known.
Now here I'm presuming that she's actually meaning that she sees anger, greed and delusion in other people.
And that it's not affecting her.
It's not coming into her.
I'm presuming that she hasn't got that within her.
because it wouldn't make sense for her to have that within her as such, because she's undercut the whole process by destroying that wrong identity from which it all arises.
But I did suggest to Nodin something else.
You'll know that there are these four levels of sanctity, of spiritual attainment, the stream-enterer, and then the once-returner, the non-returner, and the arahat.
Now, normally speaking, the way it's normally understood, the way the commentaries would normally put it, is that there's a Magga and a Pala, the path and the fruit.
And it's normally said that when a person becomes a Sotapanna, there is a moment, that initial moment, is the path.
And then all the other moments of their lives, as a Sotapanna, is the fruit of that insight.
Now...
and that's the same for them all but there's definitely evidence in the scriptures to say that actually these are two paths and this makes great sense to me personally the first one is to do with the right understanding you see where a person sees quite clearly one of these three characteristics and the seeing of these characteristics now has to be
become systemic it has to run through right attitude right speech right action right livelihood it has to manifest outwards that way and until it's done that totally we can't talk about the fruit of it so one of the arguments for that is the experience the Buddha himself had where it's said in the scriptures he has this moment of enlightenment but then Mara chases him remember for seven years
with his three daughters, sensual pleasure, eroticism and boredom.
We can see that that's where his problems lay.
He wasn't so much in power.
If you remember, Jesus was tempted by power.
He's saying to the top of the mountain about the devil.
You can have all this, you see.
So there's always power, riches and sensuality.
So that was where you might say he'd been stuck, you might say.
So seven years, Mara finally gives up on it.
Says, he sees me, Mara sees me.
But the purity had not become systemic.
There's a suggestion there.
Whether it was seven years or not, who knows?
But there's an understanding there that it took time for this huge insight, for this new liberation to find its way through all his habits,
And because his habits were still there, he would have seen them as unwholesome.
So it may be that that's also what she's referring to, and she's not yet reached the fruit of her insight.
But I prefer to see it the other way, that she has actually, and that she's quite aware when somebody's being greedy, deluded, she's not fooled by it.
But what a wonderful thing to be able to say.
I'm unable to detect even an instant when they have power.
Any power over my heart.
I want to be able to say that.
Yes, they arise and cease.
They are forever changing.
But the presence that knows them never changes for an instant.
Never changes for an instant.
And we can get a hint of that in ourselves because when you
finally, when you've isolated the sense of the observer very clearly in yourself, and then you reflect at the end of your sitting or something, what was it like to be there?
What's inside the observer?
What's it made of?
And that's where we're getting a hint that where the Buddha says, those who are mindful in this way are in the presence of Nibbana.
He's not actually saying that we can't get a taste for it, we can't get a
a feel for it.
And it's important because the more we get that feel for it, the silence of it, the lack of excitement.
Our happiness is always gauged by how happy we are emotionally, how excited we are, what the future has to offer us.
And yet here there's a pointing to some sort of stasis, some sort of peacefulness that never changes.
An internal...
position of silence you know and when we when we begin to sense that it's also begin to realize that it's not part of this process of arising and passing away it is forever there you see now that's very difficult for us to to grasp because for us there is time we can't imagine something not being in time not being caught up in some sort of changing process yeah
But she's pointing to that.
She's forever unborn and undying.
It's not part of this process of the phenomenal world.
And then finally, just this is the end of suffering.
May it be that Meichi Kyo has inspired us, driven us to greater efforts.
May we all be fully realized and free from all suffering sooner rather than later.
Sadhu.